we should also say president Trump has
had a rocky relationship with members of
the Bush family but the president
saluted his predecessor last night when
he and the first lady visited the
capital major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning good morning
all the living presidents including the
45th and current President States
President Trump will attend President
Bush's funeral Wednesday here in
Washington at the National Cathedral and
of course it's pretty clear by now and
people remember well during the campaign
some harsh words between then candidate
Trump and the Bush family a degree of
estrangement but since word came of
President Bush's passing on Friday
President Trump has been nothing but
gracious and respectful of the office
mr. Bush and the entire Bush family on
Monday President Trump tweeted that he
quote looks is looking forward to being
with the Bush family to pay my respects
the White House official tells us that
means a meeting today either at Blair
House are here at the White House
between President Trump First Lady
Melania and the entire Bush family of
course these are both Republican
presidents mr. Bush and president Trump
but very different in their approach mr.
Bush bipartisan kind gentle mr. Trump a
little bit on the noisier more
disruptive side and some certain policy
differences with President Trump now
criticizes what he calls stupid
immigration law as well as worth
pointing out those laws in part were
drafted during George HW Bush's
presidency in 1990 but policy clashes
and differences in style aside this is a
time for the nation Washington and the
institution of the peasant presidency to
pay respect and the first family is
doing everything it can to live up to
that tradition Nora
major thank you